Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
AS THE COMPETITION HEATED UP,
TENSION STARTED TO RISE.
Ebony: YOU'RE ASKING
FOR MASSAGES
WHILE WE'RE CLEANING UP.
THAT IS FRUSTRATING.
Tyra: QUESTIONS WERE RAISED
ABOUT ELYSE'S EATING HABITS.
Adrianne: SHE DOESN'T EAT
AS MUCH AS I WOULD CARE
FOR HER TO.
Tyra: AT THE JUDGING PANEL,
INSECURITY STARTED TO MOUNT.
GISELLE,
WHERE'S THE SELF-ESTEEM?
BUT IN THE END,
EBONY WAS SENT PACKING.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: DID YOU LIKE IT
BETTER WITH MORE CHICKS OR NO?
Elyse: NO.
THE FEWER CHICKS, THE BETTER.
Adrianne: YEAH.
THE FEWER CHICKS,
THE CLOSER WE ARE TO WINNING.
Giselle: AFTER
THE LAST ELIMINATION,
I JUST WAS SO--I DON'T KNOW.
THE JUDGES ARE SAYING
I TOTALLY NEED TO BUILD
SOME MORE CONFIDENCE,
AND I'M TRYING.
IT'S JUST GONNA BE
MY HARDEST TASK EVER.
Robin: COME ON, GISELLE.
(doorbell rings)
Jay: HEY!
Women: HI!
Jay: YOU HERE TO VISIT ME?
LOOK AT YOU-- YOU DIDN'T
HAVE TO GET THAT DRESSED UP.
WE'RE JUST HANGING OUT.
Giselle: WE WENT TO
JAY MANUEL'S HOUSE,
AND THAT WAS REALLY COOL.
Jay: I JUST FIGURED OUT
WHO GOT CUT.
Elyse: I REALLY LIKE JAY
A LOT.
HE'S A REALLY GOOD
MAKEUP ARTIST.
I LOVE MY MAKEUP SO MUCH
WHEN JAY DOES IT.
Tyra: HEY, Y'ALL!
Women: HI!
(laughing)
Kesse: TYRA AND JUST ALL
THEIR ASSISTANTS,
EVERYBODY WAS THERE.
SO IT WAS--IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
Jay: YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA COOK FOR US.
Robin: WE NEED SOME CHICKEN
AND SOME FLOUR
AND SOME SWEET POTATOES,
SOME GREENS.
Jay: I GOT EVERYTHING
BUT THE GREENS.
Man: GO FOR IT, HONEY.
IT'S GOOD.
Tyra: (British accent)
AND YOU CAN HAVE THIS KITCHEN
FOR $27,575.42.
Elyse: OUCH.
Man: BE CAREFUL, LADIES.
Tyra: LET ME SEE WHAT Y'ALL
GOT GOIN' HERE.
BUT WHERE'S THE SUGAR, JAY?
Robin: MISS TYRA--
SHE'S REALLY LIKE A--
LIKE A GIRLFRIEND-TYPE.
YOU KNOW, SOMEONE THAT YOU CAN,
LIKE, OPEN UP TO.
Tyra: I NEED SOME KETCHUP.
Elyse: I LIKE A LITTLE...
I LIKE A LITTLE, UH...
Tyra: SUGAR SAUCE.
Adrianne: KETCHUP. KETCHUP.
(telephone rings)
Robin: OOH, MR. JAY, CAN I
ANSWER YOUR PHONE?
WHO IS THIS CALLING MY MAN?
(laughter)
Man: YO,
THAT FOOD LOOKS GOOD.
Tyra: THIS PASTA LOOKS
ABSOLUTELY WEIRD.
All: (speaking at once)
Tyra: TYRA HAS
TO UNBUTTON HER PANTS
TO PREPARE FOR
A FEAST.
(laughter)
Giselle: IT'S KIND OF AN
ISSUE RIGHT NOW
WHETHER ELYSE HAS SOME
EATING DISORDERS OR NOT,
BUT WE'RE KIND OF CONFUSED.
WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON WITH HER.
Adrianne: I'M REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT ELYSE.
SHE'S A SMART, SMART GIRL,
BUT SHE'S NOT FOOLING ANYBODY,
AND EVEN MISS TYRA SEES IT.
Tyra: NO PASTA TONIGHT?
Kesse: ELYSE ATE, LIKE,
A WHOLE PLATE OF STUFF.
SHE MENTIONED TO SOMEBODY THAT
IT WAS BECAUSE TYRA WAS THERE.
Jay: ACTUALLY,
I'M SURPRISED
IT TASTES THIS GOOD.
YOU ATE A WHOLE PLATE OF PASTA.
Elyse: WE'VE BEEN STARVING
ALL DAY IN THE HOUSE.
CONSTANTLY DEALING WITH
THE OTHER GIRLS SCRUTINIZING
WHAT I EAT AND MY WEIGHT--
IT REALLY HAS BEEN FRUSTRATING.
Man: WHO EATS THE LEAST?
Ty: WHO EATS THE LEAST
OUT OF Y'ALL?
Elyse: PROBABLY ME.
Man: I WONDER WHY.
Ty: YOU SPOKE
FOR YOURSELF.
Elyse: I EAT WHEN I'M HUNGRY,
AND I STOP EATING WHEN I'M FULL.
Robin: THANK YOU FOR
LETTING US GRACE YOUR HOME.
Adrianne: GOOD NIGHT,
EVERYBODY.
Elyse: GOOD NIGHT.
Tyra: GOOD NIGHT.
Jay: OH, I JUST WANNA HUG HER
BECAUSE SHE'S ALL FURRY!
WHOO!
All: BYE! SEE YOU!
Tyra: BYE.
Man: BYE, Y'ALL!
♪♪♪
Elyse: OKAY, GUYS,
"PLEASE BE IN LONDON
AT 10:30 A.M..."
Giselle: YES!
Elyse: "FOR PUBLICITY
TRAINING."
Giselle: OH, COOL! MAN!
ADRIANNE AND ELYSE--
I'VE BONDED WITH THESE GIRLS.
THEY'RE MY ROOMMATES,
AND THEY MAKE ME LAUGH.
I JUST REALLY GET ALONG
WITH THEM.
OKAY, MY FACE
IS DEFINITELY PIMPLE-IZED.
I HAVE ONE HUGE ONE,
TWO HUGE ONE, THREE HUGE ONE.
CONNECT THE DOTS,
AND YOU GET A TRIANGLE.
Adrianne: GISELLE FOUND OUT
THAT PRETENDING TO BE
SO NEGATIVE ABOUT YOURSELF
AND SO INSECURE IS A GREAT WAY
TO FISH FOR COMPLIMENTS.
Giselle: MY PICTURES
CAME OUT THE WORST
OUT OF EVERYBODY'S.
Nicole: NO, THEY DIDN'T.
YOU'RE TRIPPIN'.
NO, THEY DIDN'T.
Giselle: YES. DON'T DO THAT.
AM I NOT GONNA EVER BE ABLE
TO DO A COMMERCIAL?
I HAVE A THIRD EYEBALL
ON MY FACE.
LIKE, WHAT THE HELL
AM I DOING HERE?
Adrianne: I'M GONNA THINK
ABOUT VARIOUS WAYS IN WHICH
I CAN KILL YOU TONIGHT
WHEN YOU'RE ASLEEP.
SHOULD I PUT CYANIDE
IN YOUR FOOD, OR...
Giselle: YOU'RE CRAZY.
Adrianne: IT'S JUST
I HATE YOU SO MUCH, GISELLE.
SO MUCH.
YOU'RE REALLY SLOW
IF YOU TAKE ME SERIOUSLY
AT ANY TIME IN YOUR LIFE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HEY, GUYS.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
TODAY IS PUBLICITY TRAINING,
AND PUBLICITY TRAINING
IS IMPORTANT FOR ANYONE
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY,
BUT PERSONALLY TO ME,
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
FOR MODELS BECAUSE USUALLY
PEOPLE WOULD PREFER MODELS
TO BE SEEN AND NOT HEARD.
YOU KNOW, "WE DON'T NEED
TO HEAR HER TALK.
"JUST POSE--
JUST WALK ON THE RUNWAY.
IT DOESN'T MATTER."
SO IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW TO CONDUCT AN INTERVIEW.
I HAVE MY PUBLICIST HERE TODAY.
HERE'S CINDI.
Cindi: HI. I'M CINDI.
Elyse: HI. ELYSE.
Cindi: HI, ELYSE. HI.
Shannon: HI. SHANNON.
Cindi: HI, SHANNON.
Elyse: CINDI GAVE US
A LECTURE ABOUT HOW TO DEAL
WITH REPORTERS AND WHAT TO SAY
AND WHAT NOT TO SAY.
Cindi: THE IMPORTANT
START-OFF RULE IS THAT
THAT JOURNALIST IS THERE
FOR A STORY.
THE BIG RULE IS
IF YOU MESS UP, 'FESS UP.
IF YOU'VE MADE A MISTAKE,
OWN UP TO IT.
WHEN YOU DO AN INTERVIEW,
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU REALIZE
THAT THE TRUTH ALWAYS COMES OUT.
DON'T BE AFRAID TO SHARE
INFORMATION THAT YOU MAY NOT
NECESSARILY WANT TO SHARE.
BUT HONESTY IS THE BEST WAY
TO HANDLE IT.
JUST COME CLEAN.
Kesse: IT'S JUST GOOD
THAT WE HAVE SOMEONE THAT'S
ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
TALKING TO US,
TELLING US ABOUT IT
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT POINT.
Cindi: TRUST THE PUBLICIST
SO YOUR PUBLICIST CAN GUIDE YOU.
IF YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING
IN YOUR PAST,
THE PUBLIC IS VERY FORGIVING.
Tyra: CELEBRITY, TO ME,
IS LIKE BEING
THE POPULAR KIDS IN SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY WANTS
TO KNOW THEM AND BE LIKE THEM
AND TOUCH THEM,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU WANNA,
LIKE, TALK ABOUT THEM
LIKE THIS TO BREAK 'EM DOWN.
IT MAKES YOU FEEL BETTER,
YOU KNOW, TO READ SOMETHING
ABOUT SOMEBODY THAT YOU THINK
IS SO PERFECT,
AND THEN YOU READ ABOUT THEM,
AND IT'S LIKE, "OH, SHE HAS THIS
AND SHE HAS THIS AND HER THIS,"
YOU KNOW, AND MAKES YOU
FEEL BETTER.
Elyse: THEN WE HAD
AN INTERVIEW WITH HER IN WHICH
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO TELL HER
ALL ABOUT EMBARRASSING THINGS
OR DIRT IN OUR PAST,
BECAUSE THE PREMISE IS THAT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO TELL
THE PUBLICIST EVERYTHING.
Cindi: HOW ARE YOU?
Giselle: GOOD.
Cindi: DID I OVERWHELM YOU?
Giselle: UH,
I'M A LITTLE SCARED NOW,
BUT NOT THAT REALLY BIG--
Cindi: THAT'S OKAY.
FEAR IS A GOOD THING.
Elyse: I HOPE WE CAN GET
SOME PIZZA TONIGHT.
Robin: GIRL,
YOU NOT GONNA EAT NONE.
Elyse: I'M NOT GONNA...
Robin: BUT I THINK
SHE HAS AN EATING DISORDER.
TAKING LITTLE BITES,
YOU KNOW, OF LIKE,
PEOPLE'S FOOD OR JUST, LIKE, UH,
OR ONLY EATING WHEN WE'RE
IN FRONT OF MISS TYRA.
Elyse: ROBIN,
YOU'RE AN IDIOT, AND FRANKLY,
YOU'RE STARTING TO ACT
LIKE A BITCH, TOO.
Adrianne: WHAT KIND
OF WEIRD PIZZA DO YOU LIKE?
Elyse: I LIKE
ALL KINDS OF PIZZA.
Shannon: ORGANIC?
Adrianne: NOT MINE.
Giselle: ONE DAY I'LL BE ABLE
TO MEET MICHAEL JACKSON.
Cindi: YOU WANNA MEET
MICHAEL JACKSON?
Giselle: I WANNA MEET
MICHAEL JACKSON SO BAD.
I AM JUST INFATUATED
WITH THE GUY'S TALENT,
AND HONESTLY, IF I MET HIM
FACE TO FACE, I PROBABLY
COULDN'T EVEN LOOK AT HIM.
I'D BE, LIKE,
DOING A LOT OF THIS.
I THINK HE'S AMAZING.
Kesse: SO I KINDA, LIKE,
PUSHED MYSELF BECAUSE I WAS
LIKE, I'M NOT GONNA TURN OUT
LIKE THE REST OF MY FAMILY.
Cindi: IS YOUR MOM
IN THE PICTURE?
Kesse: SHE'S THERE,
BUT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP.
SHE HAS EVERYBODY AT HOME
THINKING WE'RE THE BEST
OF FRIENDS AND ALL THAT,
AND WE HAVEN'T TALKED
IN, LIKE, THREE MONTHS.
Shannon: NEVER DRINK,
NEVER SMOKE,
AND I'M STILL A VIRGIN.
Adrianne: I EXPERIMENTED
WITH DRUGS WHEN I WAS, LIKE, 13.
I WAS A LITTLE PROMISCUOUS.
Cindi: ARE THERE ANY ISSUES
THAT MAY COME UP--WHO YOU ARE
AND WHY YOU ARE THE WAY YOU ARE?
Robin: NO, MA'AM.
I THANK THE LORD THAT I HAVE
LIVED MY LIFE, YOU KNOW,
THE WAY THAT I HAVE
FOR THE MOST PART UNLESS YOU TRY
TO, LIKE, MAKE SOMETHING UP.
YOU KNOW,
IT'S A PRETTY CLEAN SHEET.
Cindi: I'M AN OPEN BOOK
FOR YOU.
ASK ME ANYTHING.
Elyse: OKAY.
I FEEL LIKE, UM,
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE,
THERE'S BEEN THIS WHOLE, LIKE--
THE SUBPLOT IS THAT I HAVE
AN EATING DISORDER,
WHICH IS COMPLETELY FALSE,
BUT I FEEL LIKE I HAVEN'T HAD
THE CHANCE TO DEFEND MYSELF
AT ALL.
JUST NOW IN THERE, I SAID,
"I HOPE THEY CAN TAKE US
OUT FOR PIZZA TONIGHT,"
AND ROBIN GOES, "WELL, YOU KNOW
YOU WOULDN'T EAT ANY OF IT."
OH, SO UNTRUE.
SHE HAS DECIDED,
"ELYSE DOESN'T EAT."
Robin: I DIDN'T MEAN TO LIKE,
YOU KNOW, LIKE, SAY IT
BEING MEAN, BUT I WAS LIKE,
"WHY ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT FOOD?
YOU NOT GONNA EAT--
YOU NEVER EAT."
Robin: I FELT SORRY FOR HER
LAST NIGHT WHEN SHE WAS EATING
ALL THAT FOOD,
'CAUSE POOR CHILD.
I WAS LIKE, LORD,
I HOPE SHE DOESN'T THROW UP.
Adrianne: OH, MY GOD.
SHE WAS--AS SOON AS WE GOT HERE,
"GUYS, YOU NEED TO HURRY UP
IN THAT BATHROOM.
PLEASE HURRY."
GISELLE--WE BOTH SWEAR
THAT WE HEARD, LIKE, "EHH."
AND THEN, LIKE,
WITH THE WATER,
AND THEN WE HEARD
THE TOILET FLUSH.
I DON'T KNOW.
HER TEETH ARE NOT AS SHINY.
THEY'RE YELLOW.
Elyse: I'VE NEVER HAD
AN EATING PROBLEM, AND THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IN MY PAST
THAT WOULD EVER COME OUT
TO BACK UP THAT ASSERTION.
Cindi: IF THERE'S EVEN
A SMIDGEN OF SOMETHING THERE,
COME CLEAN.
Elyse: THERE'S NOT--
THERE'S NOTHING.
Cindi: THEN DON'T WORRY
ABOUT IT.
Robin: SHE LOOKS AT HERSELF
IN THE MIRROR
AND DOES LIKE THIS.
Adrianne: SHE'LL BE LIKE...
LIKE DOING THAT, AND, LIKE,
SHE'S, LIKE, SHE'S A TOOTHPICK.
THERE'S NOT AN OUNCE OF FAT
TO HER BODY.
SHE'S KILLING HERSELF.
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO PUT IT.
THIS GIRL IS KILLING HERSELF.
Cindi: IF PEOPLE ASK YOU
ABOUT IT, YOU SAY,
"I'M NOT ANOREXIC.
"I'M NOT BULIMIC.
I'M TALL AND THIN."
(telephone rings)
Elyse: HEY, MOM.
Elyse's mom: Hi.
Elyse: WHAT'S UP?
Elyse's mom: What's up
with you?
Elyse: NOTHING. SORRY.
(sniffling)
Elyse's mom: Having
a bad day?
Elyse: YEAH.
Elyse's mom: Instead of
a good day?
Elyse: YEAH.
(sobbing)
Elyse's mom: Anything you can
talk about?
Elyse: IT'S PROBLEMS
AMONG THE OTHER GIRLS.
Elyse's mom: Oh, no.
Elyse: EVERYONE IS SO
STUPID, TOO.
Elyse's mom: Sorry.
Elyse: (sobbing)
Elyse: I HATE IT HERE.
I HATE IT HERE.
Adrianne: YOU'RE ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT POTATOES.
Elyse: I DON'T GIVE A...
ABOUT WINNING
THAT STUPID COMPETITION,
BECAUSE OTHER STUFF
SUCKS SO BAD.
I NEED TO GET OUT OF HERE.
♪♪♪
Giselle: IT'S KIND OF AN
ISSUE RIGHT NOW
WHETHER ELYSE
HAS SOME EATING DISORDERS
OR NOT, BUT SOMETIMES I GET
A LITTLE WORRIED,
AND I'M LIKE, OKAY, YEAH.
SO I GOT A LITTLE CONCERNED,
AND I WAS LIKE, OKAY, WELL,
I DON'T KNOW.
Elyse: GISELLE ANNOYS ME
THE MOST OUT OF EVERYONE
IN THE HOUSE, AND I'M NOT
WILLING TO ALIENATE GISELLE
BECAUSE SHE'S THE ONLY ONE
IN TOKYO
WITH A STRAIGHTENING IRON.
Giselle: IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE YOU'RE EVER HUNGRY,
AND I GUESS IT'S LIKE
IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE HAPPY
WITH YOURSELF.
Elyse: I'M FINE WITH MYSELF.
Giselle: FINE WITH YOURSELF--
SEE?
Elyse: I DON'T THINK I'M FAT-- I
KNOW I'M SKINNY, BUT I LIKE IT.
I'M SO DEFENSIVE BECAUSE
I NEVER GET A CHANCE
TO EXPLAIN MYSELF, EVER.
I'VE NEVER, EVER MADE MYSELF
THROW UP, AND I'VE NEVER
ABUSED LAXATIVES,
BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S BAD FOR YOU.
I HAVE BEEN TRYING TO SUPPRESS
MY INTELLECTUAL SUPERIORITY.
HOWEVER, I CAN CONFIDENTLY SAY
THAT I KNOW MORE ABOUT
EATING DISORDERS THAN ALL OF
THE REST OF THE GIRLS COMBINED.
Elyse: SOMETIMES I WANNA GET
THE HELL OUT
OF THIS ENVIRONMENT.
Giselle: YOU KNOW
YOU CAN, RIGHT?
Elyse: YEAH.
Giselle: SOMETIMES
OR MOST OF THE TIME?
Elyse: SOMETIMES.
I DON'T QUIT ANYTHING.
Giselle: SO NO WAY
YOU WOULD EVER...
Elyse: NO, BUT I'M SURE
I'LL GET ELIMINATED.
Giselle: BUT YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET ELIMINATED BEFORE ME.
Elyse: AND WE'LL SEE.
♪♪♪
Giselle: TYRA MAIL!
Adrianne: LET ME OPEN IT.
"IT'S SOUL TO SOUL TIME
WITH SOME SOULFUL GRINDS.
BE READY TO CHAT WITH TYRA
AT 8:30.
DRESS COMFORTABLY
FOR A NIGHT AT HOME."
Elyse: ALL RIGHT!
♪♪♪
Robin: THIS IS SHANNON
RIGHT HERE.
Women: (laughing)
Adrianne: SEE? LOOK.
YOU'RE KINDA GETTING CLEAVAGE
ON THIS SIDE.
Robin: THIS IS ADRIANNE.
(laughing)
Adrianne: YEAH, NOW...
Elyse: MY WAY
IS EQUALLY AS GOOD.
I'M COMFORTABLE WITH MY BODY.
I REALIZE THAT I'M VERY SKINNY.
I HAVE NO DESIRE
TO GAIN OR LOSE WEIGHT.
Adrianne: YOU'VE GOT BOOBS
THE SIZE OF MY BOOBS.
WAIT, THEY LOOK EVEN BIGGER
THAN MY BOOBS,
EXCEPT FOR THE FRONT.
YOU'RE GONNA STUFF
THE OTHER SIDE?
YOU GOT THE AIR PUSH-UP BRA,
TWO SILICONE INSERTS
AND TOILET PAPER.
YOU'VE GOT ENORMOUS CHA-CHAS.
OH, MY GOD.
Tyra: HEY, Y'ALL.
Robin: HEY, MISS TYRA.
Tyra: ARE WE MATCHING?
Giselle: YES, WE ARE.
Tyra: YOU GUYS WANNA
COME OVER TO TOKYO?
YOU WANNA TALK?
BRING YOUR BLANKETS
AND YOUR PILLOWS AND STUFF,
AND WE'RE GONNA SIT
ON THE FLOOR.
Robin: AW!
♪ HOW BEAUTIFUL ♪♪
Giselle: OH, THIS IS AWESOME.
Kesse: WE REALLY KINDA
BONDED WITH EACH OTHER
AND, YOU KNOW, JUST GETTING
TO KNOW EACH OTHER'S FEELINGS
AND STUFF.
Tyra: SOMETIMES YOU CAN BE
VERY SECURE, BUT THEN YOU ENTER
THE MODELING INDUSTRY,
AND IT CREATES
ALL THESE INSECURITIES
THAT YOU NEVER HAD.
SO WE'RE JUST GONNA KINDA
ADDRESS ALL THAT TYPE OF STUFF
TONIGHT.
IS THERE ANYBODY
IN YOUR GUYS' LIFE THAT, UM,
YOU FEEL, LIKE,
DOESN'T BELIEVE IN YOU?
I THINK WE ALL HAVE SOMEBODY.
Giselle: MY FAMILY,
LIKE, IN UNISON--
THEY REALLY, REALLY DON'T THINK
THAT I CAN DO ANYTHING.
MY MOM--SHE FOUND OUT THAT I WAS
GOING TO NEW YORK TO DO THIS.
UH, SHE WAS LIKE, "GISELLE,
COME ON, BE REALISTIC.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET FAR."
AUTOMATICALLY, MY WHOLE FAMILY
IS LIKE, "YOU ARE SO STUPID."
MY WHOLE LIFE
I'VE BEEN SHOT DOWN,
AND MY MOM IS ALWAYS LIKE,
"WHO DO YOU THINK YOU ARE?"
AND I JUST--I MEAN, BEAUTY HAS
NEVER BEEN, LIKE, A THING
IN MY HOUSE.
Tyra: IT'S INTERESTING TO ME,
THOUGH, LIKE, HOW MOMS CAN BE.
EVERYBODY'S MAMA SOMETIMES--
AS MUCH AS WE LOVE THEM,
SOMETIMES IT'S LIKE YOU DON'T
REALIZE YOU'RE MAKING ME
MORE INSECURE THAN I AM.
Kesse: THIS IS SOMETHING
I WANT TO PURSUE.
I WANT TO BE IN THE INDUSTRY.
NOBODY KNOWS I'M HERE
BESIDES THE PEOPLE
I LIVE WITH AT HOME.
MY MOTHER DOESN'T KNOW I'M HERE.
NOBODY KNOWS.
I AM IN SCHOOL, AND I'LL BE
THE FIRST ONE TO GRADUATE
IN MY FAMILY WITH A DEGREE.
I MEAN, MY LIFE AT HOME WASN'T--
I DON'T KNOW.
SOMETIMES I JUST GET DEPRESSED
ABOUT BEING AT HOME.
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE,
AND I MEAN, I WISH I COULD
STAY HERE, YOU KNOW, FOREVER.
Tyra: ROBIN, WHAT ABOUT YOU?
ANY INSECURITIES?
Robin: NOT FITTING INTO
A MODEL--LIKE, TYPICAL MODEL
MODE OR WHATEVER.
I HAVE NOTHING TO BE ASHAMED OF,
YOU KNOW?
I HAVE EMBRACED EVERY CURVE
THAT IS ON MY BODY.
IF MORE WOMEN DO,
THEN, YOU KNOW,
WE WOULDN'T HAVE PROBLEMS
LIKE BULIMIA AND ANOREXIA
AND, YOU KNOW, THINGS LIKE THAT
MAKING WOMEN FEEL INSECURE.
AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S THE REASON WHY
I'M STILL HERE.
Tyra: WHAT ABOUT YOU, ELYSE?
ANY NEW INSECURITIES
BEING HERE?
Elyse: SUDDENLY HERE I AM,
AND I'M TOO SKINNY,
SO I KINDA FEEL--I ALTERNATE
BETWEEN, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
CRAMMING A COUPLE EXTRA BITES
OF FOOD--LET'S CHANGE IT--
AND, LIKE, "COME ON, ELYSE.
YOU KNOW, STOP EATING
WHEN YOU'RE NOT HUNGRY ANYMORE."
Tyra: DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL
ANGRY OR SAD OR...
Elyse: UM, IT KIND OF--
IT MAKES ME FEEL
A LITTLE BIT ANGRY.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ME FEEL SAD.
BUT I DO--
I FEEL REALLY CONFUSED.
Tyra: SO EVEN MORE THAN
SOMEBODY TELLING YOU,
YOU KNOW, YOU NEED TO LOSE
OR GAIN OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE,
IT'S BEING AT WORK AND SEEING,
"OH, MY GOD.
I HAVE NEVER IN MY LIFE
SEEN A WOMAN THAT BEAUTIFUL,"
AND THAT'S WHERE THE INSECURITY
STARTS COMING IN.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S HAVE
A NICE HUG AROUND THE CANDLES.
Adrianne: I SMELL
A HEAT WAVE AROUND HERE.
Giselle: OH, GOD.
Tyra: WHAT'S A HEAT WAVE,
A FART?
Elyse: GISELLE COINED
THE TERM "HEAT WAVE"
AS A EUPHEMISM FOR FARTS,
WHICH I THINK THUS FAR IS
HER MAJOR CONTRIBUTION
TO SOCIETY.
Tyra: YOU KNOW,
I'LL MAKE A CONFESSION.
WHEN WE STOOD UP,
I MADE THE TINIEST LITTLE FART
JUST NOW.
Shannon: OH, MY WORD!
Women: (speaking at once)
Tyra: IT WAS SO TINY.
♪♪♪
Giselle: WE HAD A NICE LITTLE
PUBLICITY INTERVIEW CHALLENGE
IN CENTRAL PARK.
Steve: HI, LADIES,
I'M STEVE SANTAGATI,
AND I AM WORKING MEMBER
OF THE PRESS.
TODAY I AM
GOING TO BE CONDUCTING
YOUR PUBLICITY CHALLENGE.
IT'S GONNA TAKE THE FORM
OF A TELEVISION INTERVIEW.
WE WANT REAL SOUND BITES.
WE WANT YOU TO BE VULNERABLE.
WE WANT YOU TO TELL US WHAT
YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT THINGS.
THE DAYS OF CANNED PERFORMANCES
AND CANNED INTERVIEWS ARE OVER.
I'M GONNA TAKE EACH OF YOU
FOR A RIDE FOR ABOUT 15 MINUTES
IN THE CARRIAGE HERE,
AND I'M GONNA TALK TO YOU.
THE TWO WINNERS WILL HAVE
ONE OF THEIR LOVED ONES
FLOWN IN.
Elyse: I JUST WANT
MY BOYFRIEND TO HANG OUT
WITH ME A LITTLE BIT.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE REALLY
BEEN MISSING.
Giselle: WELL,
I WILL DEFINITELY GO FOR IT.
I MISS MY BOYFRIEND A LOT.
Steve: WHO WANTS TO BE FIRST?
OKAY.
Adrianne: I MEAN,
EVERYBODY WANTED
THEIR BOYFRIENDS TO COME.
I WANT MY MOM TO COME.
Steve: WHY DO YOU WANNA BE
A MODEL?
Adrianne: I'M A REAL BIG
TOMBOY, AND I LOVE THEM
TRANSFORMING ME INTO A WOMAN.
Robin: IN MY LIFE,
I STRIVE FOR PERFECTION,
AND MY RELIGION TEACHES ME THAT.
EVERYTHING THAT I TRY TO DO,
I TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S MORALLY CORRECT.
Kesse: I'M LIKE,
I'M REAL SASSY BUT CLASSY.
Shannon: NEVER DRINK,
NEVER SMOKE,
AND I'M STILL A VIRGIN.
Steve: I WOULD THINK THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A HARD TIME
BEING A MODEL
AND BEING A CHRISTIAN.
Shannon: WELL,
THAT'S YOUR OPINION,
BUT I CAN DO IT.
IF I SET MY MIND TO SOMETHING,
I CAN DO IT.
Steve: SEX.
Adrianne: SEX.
Steve: FIRST TIME--
HOW OLD WERE YOU?
Adrianne: I THINK
I WAS LIKE, 16,
Steve: YOU'RE STILL A VIRGIN?
Robin: UM,
MY SEXUAL PREFERENCE
AND MY SEXUAL EXPERIENCE--
I'M A LADY, AND I, YOU KNOW,
WOULD LIKE TO KEEP THAT SACRED.
Steve: NO SKELETONS
IN YOUR CLOSET?
Kesse: I GO TO SCHOOL.
I'M A FULL-TIME STUDENT.
I REMEMBER EVERYTHING
MISS CINDI SAID,
AND I, YOU KNOW, WAS VERY,
YOU KNOW, VAGUE
ON A LOT OF THINGS.
Steve: IS THERE ANYTHING
YOU WON'T MODEL?
Giselle: I WON'T MODEL NUDE.
Steve: ALL RIGHT,
WHAT IF I OFFERED YOU $20,000?
Giselle: NO.
Steve: $100,000?
Giselle: A MILLION,
KATRILLION, I WOULDN'T.
Steve: ADRIANNE,
WHAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TO YOU IN LIFE?
Adrianne: MY MOM.
Steve: YOUR MOM? WHY IS THAT?
Adrianne: BECAUSE I LOVE HER
SO MUCH, AND SHE'S HELPED ME
SO MUCH WITH TRYING
TO GET INTO MODELING.
LIKE, WE'VE BEEN RIPPED OFF
A LOT.
Steve: BY WHO?
Adrianne: MODELING SCAMS,
SEARCHES.
Elyse: HI.
Steve: HEY!
Elyse: YOU MUST BE COLD.
Steve: UH, YEAH.
Elyse: ONE THING THAT I DID
IN MY INTERVIEW THAT I THINK
MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD
IS I DID SAY NEGATIVE THINGS
ABOUT THE OTHER GIRLS.
I THINK GISELLE IS
VERY IMMATURE.
ADRIANNE IS THE WORST LISTENER
I'VE EVER ENCOUNTERED.
THEN I THINK ROBIN AND SHANNON
ARE A LITTLE BIT PROSELYTIZING,
AND ACTUALLY KESSE--
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING NEGATIVE
TO SAY ABOUT KESSE.
SHE'S GREAT.
Steve: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT ALL THIS RELIGION?
I'VE TALKED TO SO MANY
OF THE WOMEN TODAY.
HOW DOES THAT FIT IN HERE?
Elyse: I THINK THAT
IT WILL BE MORE OF A HINDRANCE
TO THE STRONG CHRISTIANS
THAN IT WILL BE
AN ADVANTAGE TO THEM.
I MEAN, THEY'VE ALREADY
EXPRESSED DISCOMFORT
WITH HOMOSEXUALITY
AND WITH NUDITY.
Steve: HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT NUDITY?
Elyse: I AM COMPLETELY
COMFORTABLE WITH NUDITY.
I'M AN E.M.T. AND I'VE WORKED
A LOT IN MEDICINE,
AND SO I JUST LOOK AT IT LIKE,
YOU KNOW, DOES SOMEBODY REALLY
WANNA SEE THE FATTENED GLANDS
HANGING OFF MY CHEST?
IF THEY DO, THAT'S FINE WITH ME.
Steve: I JUST FEEL LIKE,
YOU KNOW, NO ONE'S THAT PERFECT.
NO ONE'S THAT TOGETHER.
Robin: RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
WELL, YOU MET ROBIN TODAY.
♪♪♪
Steve: ALL RIGHT,
YOU GUYS, NOW FIRST OF ALL,
THE TRUTH IS YOU ALL DID
A GOOD JOB.
MY DECISION IS BASED
ON MY EXPERIENCE
FROM INTERVIEWING EVERYBODY
FROM FIREMEN TO JENNIFER LOPEZ.
ADRIANNE, I THOUGHT
YOU WERE VERY REAL.
ROBIN, YOUR RELIGION
IS ON YOUR SLEEVE,
AND THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER ONE--
A COUPLE OF THE OTHER
CHRISTIAN PEOPLE.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH RELIGIONS AT ALL,
BUT YOU BECOME ONE-DIMENSIONAL.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
VERY BUBBLY AND FUN.
YOU WERE A LOT OF FUN,
AND MY DECISION WAS
VERY, VERY DIFFICULT TO MAKE.
GISELLE, YOU WERE GREAT, TOO,
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T LET ME
GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING.
KESSE, VERY MOTIVATED PERSON.
ELYSE, YOU'RE MY WINNER,
AND I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHY.
YOU DID THINGS THAT YOU SHOULD
NEVER DO IN INTERVIEWS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE.
YOU WERE OUTSPOKEN.
YOU SAID THINGS
THAT YOU SHOULDN'T SAY.
YOU WERE VERY PERSONAL.
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT ARE TEXTBOOK WRONG
IN AN INTERVIEW, BUT THEY WORK,
BECAUSE IT'S REAL,
AND THAT'S WHO YOU ARE.
MY OPINION IS IS
THAT WHERE THINGS SHOULD GO.
Giselle: HE CHOOSES ELYSE
BECAUSE SHE TOTALLY WENT
AGAINST EVERYTHING IN THE BOOK.
I GUESS THAT'S GOOD FOR HIM,
BECAUSE HE CAN GET A STORY
OUT OF HER.
WHATEVER.
Steve: SO THERE'S GONNA BE
TWO WINNERS, OKAY?
YOU'RE ONE, AND YOU HAVE TO PICK
THE OTHER ONE.
Elyse: ADRIANNE.
Steve: ADRIANNE GOT IT.
Shannon: YOUR MOM'S COMIN',
BABY!
THAT JUST BLESSES ME SO MUCH
TO LET HER MOTHER COME SOMEWHERE
THAT SHE MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO IF SHE DIDN'T HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
SHE'S COMIN' TO NEW YORK,
ADRIANNE!
Adrianne: I'M JUST SO HAPPY
THAT I GOT THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE HER COME OUT HERE,
'CAUSE SHE AIN'T NEVER SEEN
TIMES SQUARE OR NOTHIN'.
Shannon: YAY!
♪♪♪
Elyse: OH, HEY,
THERE'S TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL HAVE
YOUR FIFTH PHOTO SHOOT.
PLEASE BE READY BY 8:15 A.M."
Adrianne: I WONDER IF MY MOM
CAN MEET TYRA.
DO YOU THINK
SHE WOULD MEET MY MOM?
Giselle: I WAS
VERY DISAPPOINTED
THAT I COULDN'T BRING ANYBODY.
ARE YOU EXCITED TO SEE MARTY?
Elyse: YEAH,
ON THE SAME NOTE, I'M LIKE,
I DON'T WANT HIM
TO SEE ME LIKE THIS.
Giselle: ESPECIALLY TOMORROW.
Elyse: WHAT'S TOMORROW?
Giselle: OUR PHOTO SHOOT.
Elyse: THEY'RE NOT GONNA
LET HIM COME.
IT MAKES ME FEEL GOOD
THAT MY BOYFRIEND'S
GONNA COME OUT,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I FEEL BAD THAT HE HAS TO
SEE ME LIKE THIS,
BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THIS BEING HERE,
BEING AROUND THESE GIRLS,
BEING IN THE SITUATION
HAS BROUGHT OUT
THE ABSOLUTE WORST
IN MY PERSONALITY.
Giselle: I NEED TO BUILD
SOME FRICKIN' CONFIDENCE.
HOW DO I DO THAT?
Elyse: YOU GET OUT
OF PUBERTY.
♪♪♪
(knock on door)
Jon: KNOCK, KNOCK.
WHERE IS EVERYBODY?
HEY, NOW!
Shannon: I KNEW IT!
Jon: WE'RE GOING FOR A SWIM.
OKAY? FIVE MINUTES,
AND GET A BATHING SUIT.
Robin: IS IT
CHLORINE WATER?
Jon: IT'S PROBABLY CHLORINE.
USUALLY IN POOLS,
IT'S CHLORINE,
SO YOU'LL HAVE TO
DO YOUR HAIR LATER.
♪♪♪
Elyse: I LOVE TO SWIM,
AND I WAS SO EXCITED THAT WE GOT
TO GET IN THE POOL.
Jon: COME ON,
BRING IT BACK NOW!
Elyse: I WAS ALSO
DISAPPOINTED IN THE OTHER GIRLS
BEING SO AGAINST
GETTING THEIR HAIR WET.
Jon: ROBIN,
GET YOUR HEAD DOWN!
YOU GOTTA GET
ALL THE WAY UNDER!
ADRIANNE, WOULD YOU GET
IN THERE?
THE STAR TODAY SWIMMING
PROBABLY WAS ELYSE,
BECAUSE SHE HAS BEEN ABLE
TO KEEP UP WITH THE GROUP
AND ACTUALLY PUSH--
NOT JUST KEEP UP, BUT PUSH.
SHE'S SHOWING THAT SHE PROBABLY
DOESN'T HAVE AN EATING DISORDER.
♪♪♪
Elyse: TODAY
WE'RE AT PIER 59 STUDIOS,
AND WE'RE SHOOTING AN AD
FOR REEBOK.
THE EMPHASIS IS ON
ATHLETICISM AND MOTION.
Tyra: CAN I HAVE
THE CHICAS RIGHT HERE, PLEASE?
SO TODAY WHAT WE ARE WORKING ON
AT THIS PHOTO SHOOT TODAY
IS MOVEMENT.
NO MATTER HOW
FINE YOU ARE AS A MODEL,
NO MATTER HOW GOOD YOU LOOK,
IF YOU CAN'T MOVE,
YOU CANNOT WORK.
WE'RE GONNA PUT ON SOME MUSIC
AND SEE HOW WELL YOU CAN
"MODEL DANCE."
AND REMEMBER,
MODEL DANCING IS NOT...
MODEL DANCING IS...
(imitates bass drumbeats)
MAKING SURE YOU CAPTURE
THOSE MOMENTS.
AND WE HAVE A LITTLE
SPECIAL SOMEBODY THAT IS
GOING TO ACCOMPANY YOU
IN THE PICTURES.
SO WE CAN EVALUATE
HOW WELL YOU POSE
WITH ANOTHER SUBJECT.
HE IS THE RUNNING BACK
FOR THE DENVER BRONCOS,
AND HE IS
THE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
HIS NAME IS CLINTON PORTIS.
COME ON OUT HERE.
♪♪♪
HE'S GONNA BE VERY SEXIFIED.
TODAY THE PHOTOGRAPHER
IS SUPER FIERCE.
I'VE SHOT WITH HIM, AND HE HAS
SOME OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PICTURES OF MY WHOLE CAREER.
AND HIS NAME IS DANIEL GARRIGA.
Daniel: WHAT'S GOING ON, BRO?
Clinton: WHAT'S HAPPENIN'?
Daniel: HOW ARE YOU?
Derek: I NEED AN EAGLE.
YOU WANNA BE AN EAGLE?
Adrianne: YOU CAN MAKE ME
WHATEVER YOU WANT, BABY.
Derek: YOU GOT IT.
Kesse: WE COME IN HERE,
WE GET THESE LITTLE JERSEYS,
AND THEN THE DESIGNERS, LIKE,
RIP 'EM APART
AND PUT SHOESTRINGS IN 'EM.
Derek: COMPLETELY JUST
DECONSTRUCT THIS
TO MAKE IT LOOK SEXY.
♪♪♪
Elyse: MY EYE MAKEUP, I THINK,
IS SUPPOSED TO
VAGUELY SYMBOLIZE
THE MAKEUP OF A FOOTBALL PLAYER.
Daniel: WARM UP
OVER THERE, PLEASE.
Giselle: OH, OKAY.
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
TO GO FIRST.
SO I JUST GET CONFUSED.
I MEAN, IF IT REALLY SUCKS,
LET ME KNOW.
Daniel: I USUALLY LIKE IT,
SO DON'T WORRY.
Adrianne: GISELLE--
SHE WANTS PEOPLE TO TELL HER
HOW WONDERFUL SHE IS,
HOW BEAUTIFUL SHE IS.
Giselle: I FEEL LIKE
I'M DOING TOO MUCH DANCER
AND NOT MODEL.
BECAUSE A LOT OF DANCING
IS SHOWING THROUGH THIS.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE THE MODEL PART
IS COMING THROUGH.
Daniel: GISELLE'S
A GREAT MODEL.
SHE'S OBVIOUSLY A DANCER.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN HER POSES.
WE HAVE MORE THAN THREE, SO...
Tyra: YEAH, WE GOT IT,
WE GOT IT.
Daniel: WE'RE DONE.
Tyra: THANK YOU.
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
Daniel: FAKE IT
A LITTLE BIT.
DON'T LOOK--DON'T TURN TOO MUCH,
'CAUSE I WON'T SEE YOUR FACE.
Shannon: I TEND TO BE
A LITTLE STIFF
WITH DANCE MOVES BECAUSE
I CAN'T REALLY DANCE YET,
BUT I'M LEARNIN'.
Daniel: I THINK
SHANNON SHOWS POTENTIAL.
YOU KNOW, SHE'S NOT A DANCER,
SO SHE'S NOT AS FLEXIBLE
AND SHE'S NOT AS FUNKY
AS THE FIRST ONE.
I SAW A LOT OF MOVEMENT,
BUT IT'S REALLY--
SHE LOOKS LIKE
A MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M READY, SWEETIE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: LIKE THIS. UHH!
GIVES IT MORE, YOU KNOW...
Daniel: FACE. OKAY, FACE.
SHE'S A GREAT-LOOKING GIRL,
BUT SHE LOOKS BETTER
IN PICTURES THAN IN REAL LIFE.
THAT'S WHAT A MODEL SHOULD BE.
♪♪♪
Daniel: FOCUS ON YOU.
LIKE, JUST MOVE WITH HIM, OKAY?
♪♪♪
Robin: IT JUST SEEMED
KINDA DIFFICULT.
CLINTON--HE WAS,
LIKE, TRYING TO SAY STUFF.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'?
LIKE, IT WAS, LIKE,
A DISTRACTION.
Daniel: DON'T FOCUS ON HIM
SO MUCH.
Robin: OKAY.
Daniel: FOCUS ON YOU.
LIKE, JUST MOVE WITH HIM.
Tyra: COME ON, ROBIN,
PUT YOUR BACK INTO IT.
♪♪♪
Elyse: MY BOYFRIEND HAS NEVER
SEEN ME MODEL BEFORE,
NOT THAT I REALLY DO A LOT
OF MODELING IN ALBUQUERQUE,
BUT EVEN IF I DID,
I DON'T THINK I WOULD EVER
INVITE HIM ALONG.
Adrianne: MAMA!
I TURN AROUND...
AND MY MOM WAS STANDING THERE.
Elyse: I'M CRYING.
Jay: ELYSE, DON'T CRY OFF
THAT MAKEUP NOW.
Man: DON'T FORGET,
CRY WITHOUT MAKEUP, HONEY.
Marty: I'VE JUST BEEN
SITTIN' AROUND THE HOTEL.
Shannon: IT WAS SO ROMANTIC
AND SO LOVING.
LIKE, HE JUST, LIKE, GAVE HER
A HUG AND STARTED KISSING HER,
DIDN'T CARE WHO WAS AROUND.
HE JUST WAS, LIKE,
TOTALLY FOCUSED ON HER.
Elyse: I WISH YOU DIDN'T
HAVE TO SEE ME LIKE THIS.
Marty: YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
Elyse: I TOLD MARTY
TO STAY BEHIND THE PARTITIONS
AND NOT TO WATCH ME,
BUT, UM, DURING THE SHOOT,
I LOOKED OVER, AND OF COURSE,
HE WAS WATCHING ANYWAY.
♪♪♪
Tyra: CAN YOU PUT
YOUR LEG UP HIGHER?
Marty: IT'S GOOD
TO SEE HER DOING IT.
SHE SEEMS LIKE A NATURAL AT IT.
Daniel: ELYSE--
MY FAVORITE, WITHOUT A DOUBT.
IF I HAD A BIG JOB TOMORROW,
I WOULD BOOK HER, 'CAUSE SHE'S--
SHE'S JUST GOT IT.
Adrianne: GREASE ME
LIKE YOU'RE MY MAMA.
Daniel: GUYS,
WE NEED SOME MUSIC HERE, PLEASE.
Man: MUSIC?
♪ GOODNESS GRACIOUS
THIS PLACE IS SO SPACIOUS ♪
♪ I'M FEELIN' SO LIVE
AND VIVACIOUS ♪
♪ BLESSED WITH THE ANCIENT... ♪
Daniel: ADRIANNE WAS-- OVERALL
IS A GREAT MODEL.
SHE'S BEAUTIFUL--
SHE HAD A GREAT FACE.
SHE'S VERY ATHLETIC.
♪ BACK WITH THE BUM RUSH
MAKE 'EM HUSH ♪
♪ KNOCK 'EM OUT FLUSH
SHAKE 'EM OUT THEIR SHOES... ♪
Adrianne's mom: I CAN'T
BELIEVE I ACTUALLY GAVE BIRTH
TO SUCH A BEAUTIFUL HUMAN BEING.
(laughing)
♪ MAJOR FLAVOR ♪
♪ NOW WE CAN'T GET YOU
DANCIN'... ♪♪
Adrianne: I WANT CLOTHES.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
THAT'S A WRAP.
♪♪♪
Marty: THIS IS YOUR SECTION?
Elyse: UH-HUH.
Marty: THIS IS COOL.
Adrianne: THIS IS MY BED.
COME HERE, MOM.
Adrianne's mom: BEAUTIFUL.
YOU BELONG IN TOKYO.
Adrianne: I REALLY MISSED
MY MOM, AND IT KICKS ASS
TO HAVE HER HERE--
LIKE, A LOT OF ASS.
MOM, I WANNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE'VE LOST HOW MUCH MONEY.
Adrianne's mom: I HAVEN'T
LOST A THING.
Adrianne: UM, REMEMBER WE GOT
RIPPED OFF BECAUSE OF PICTURES
AND WE GOT RIPPED OFF
AT THE MODELING SEARCHES?
Adrianne's mom: ADRIANNE.
Adrianne: THIS COULD BE,
LIKE, THE BIGGEST BREAK
WE'VE EVER HAD IN OUR LIVES.
Adrianne's mom: DON'T SAY
"WE."
IT'S YOUR--
Adrianne: WELL, IT'S ME,
BUT I'M GONNA PAY OFF
YOUR BILLS, MOM.
Adrianne's mom: OH,
WOULD YOU STOP IT?
Elyse: DINNER'S ALMOST READY
IF YOU GUYS WANNA EAT.
IT TASTES DELICIOUS 'CAUSE
WE MADE IT WITH OUR OWN HANDS.
Adrianne: WHAT DO YOU WANT?
SPAGHETTI, WHAT?
ROBIN STAYED IN HER ROOM.
THAT WAS THE RUDEST,
MOST UNCOUTH THING TO DO.
OBVIOUSLY SHE WASN'T
WELL-RAISED, YOU KNOW?
HEY, WHEN YOU'RE DONE
GETTING THAT PASTA,
PASS IT DOWN HERE
SO MY MOM CAN GET SOME.
YOU WANT SOME FISH, GIRL?
Kesse: YES.
Adrianne: I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ELYSE
WITH HER EATING.
Marty: THE EATING DISORDER
NONSENSE IS RIDICULOUS.
ELYSE IS THE PERSON THAT RIGHT
AFTER I'VE EVEN FINISHED EATING,
ALREADY WANTS TO GO
TO THE ICE CREAM PARLOR
AND HAVE KIT KAT.
Giselle: UH-OH!
DID YOU GUYS READ THIS ALREADY?
Adrianne: THIS IS TYRA MAIL.
THIS IS OUR DOOM.
"TOMORROW FIVE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Giselle: I'M GOING HOME,
BUT I TOLD HIM--
YEAH, I TOLD MY BOYFRIEND
THAT I WAS GOING HOME
THIS WEEKEND
WITH TOMORROW'S OUTCOME.
Adrianne: PRAY
THAT I STAY HERE, MA.
Elyse: I THOUGHT THAT
SEEING MARTY MIGHT MAKE
BEING HERE A LITTLE BIT HARDER
AND BEING AWAY FROM HIM
A LITTLE BIT MORE STRESSFUL,
BUT NOW THAT I'VE SEEN HIM,
I FEEL SO MUCH BETTER.
I'M REALLY GLAD
I GOT THE CHANCE TO.
I'M GLAD YOU GOT TO SEE MY DIGS.
Adrianne: THANKS FOR COMING,
MOM.
Adrianne's mom: I LOVE YOU.
Adrianne: I'M GONNA WIN.
Adrianne's mom: GOOD.
GOOD LUCK.
Adrianne: I LOVE YOU, MAMA.
Adrianne's mom: I LOVE YOU,
TOO.
Adrianne: MY MOTHER
REMINDED ME THE REASONS
THAT I WANTED TO WIN,
SO I HAVE A LOT MORE DRIVE,
LIKE, THAN BEFORE.
Adrianne's mom: BYE,
HONEY BUNNY.
Adrianne: I LOVE YOU, MAMA.
Adrianne's mom: I LOVE YOU,
TOO.
Adrianne: BYE, MOM.
I'LL CALL YOU
AFTER I'M NOT ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: WHEN IS
THIS ELIMINATION GONNA BE?
THIS IS MADNESS.
I HOPE NONE OF THEM
FROM THE DIVA SUITE
MOVE OVER HERE.
I'D FEEL SO BAD FOR THEM
IF THEY DO.
LIKE SHANNON...
Shannon: THANKS, DIVA.
I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS
FOR EVERY ELIMINATION.
YOU GOTTA BE READY.
YOU GOTTA BE PREPARED
FOR THE WORST OR, YOU KNOW,
OR THE BEST.
Kesse: I'M JUST, UM,
HOPING AND PRAYING THAT I'M NOT
THE ONE TO GET ELIMINATED TODAY.
Tyra: WELCOME, LADIES.
IT'S BEEN ANOTHER
CHALLENGING WEEK
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW THIS WEEK YOU GOT
YOUR FIRST TASTE OF WHAT
IT'S LIKE FOR A TOP MODEL
TO BE LIVING IN THE PUBLIC EYE.
YOU'VE HAD PUBLICITY LESSONS,
YOU'VE INTERVIEWED
WITH A TOP JOURNALIST,
AND YOU EVEN GOT TO PHOTOGRAPH
WITH A TOP FOOTBALL STAR.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR FIFTH CUT.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A REVLON CONTRACT,
A CONTRACT WITH
WILHELMINA MODELS, INC.
AND A FASHION SPREAD
IN "MARIE CLAIRE."
AND ONCE AGAIN, WE HAVE
OUR PANEL OF EXPERT JUDGES
THAT HAVE, WEEK BY WEEK,
JUDGED YOU.
FIRST, WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE FIRST SUPERMODELS,
AND WE HAVE BEAU QUILLIAN,
THE FASHION EDITOR
OF "MARIE CLAIRE,"
KIMORA LEE SIMMONS,
THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR AND OWNER
OF BABY PHAT FASHIONS,
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
STEVE SANTAGATI,
WHO CONDUCTED YOUR INTERVIEWS.
WE'LL BRING YOU IN ONE BY ONE
FOR INDIVIDUAL ANALYSIS.
AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
WE'LL CALL YOU BACK IN,
AND WE'LL MAKE OUR ELIMINATION.
WE'VE RANDOMLY DRAWN NAMES,
AND, ROBIN, YOU'RE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT, ROBIN, NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATION.
Steve: SO I HAVE
TWO TOUGH QUESTIONS
FOR YOU TODAY.
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU SHOULD WIN
THIS COMPETITION?
Robin: I THINK THAT I SHOULD
WIN THIS COMPETITION
NOT FOR THE OBVIOUS REASONS,
WHICH IS FAME AND FORTUNE,
BUT I'M LOOKING AT IT
FOR THE POWER THAT IT CAN GIVE
TO ME TO USE AS A PLATFORM
TO BE AN INFLUENCE
ON SOMEONE'S LIFE.
Elyse: I SORT OF BREAK
STEREOTYPES ON BOTH SIDES
OF SORT OF THE TWO WORLDS
THAT I INHABIT, WHICH IS
A NERDY PERSON WHO IS
ATTRACTIVE PHYSICALLY,
AND ALSO A MODEL
WHO IS INTELLIGENT.
Adrianne: I THINK THAT, UH,
I'M PUTTING A LITTLE SPICE
IN THE INDUSTRY.
Shannon: I'M WILLING TO, UM,
STAY STRONG.
I DON'T THINK THAT TEMPTATIONS
IN THE MODELING WORLD
I CAN BE EASILY PERSUADED.
Giselle: I FEEL I SHOULD WIN
THIS COMPETITION BECAUSE
I HAVE THE PERSONALITY FOR IT.
I AM RIGHT NOW
BUILDING CONFIDENCE.
YES, I AM.
Kesse: IT'S BEEN A DREAM
OF MINE, YOU KNOW,
FOR A LONG TIME.
I DESERVE TO BE HAPPY
AT LEAST ONCE IN MY LIFE.
Steve: SO WHO SHOULD WE
ELIMINATE TODAY?
Robin: WHATEVER PERSON THAT,
UH, GOD PUTS ON YOUR HEART
TO ELIMINATE.
Elyse: I WOULD KICK OUT
ROBIN.
LIKE, HER RELIGION,
RECENTLY EVEN MORE SO THAN WHEN
I FIRST MET HER,
HAS REALLY HAMPERED HER
IN BEING INHIBITED.
Adrianne: ROBIN OR SHANNON
JUST BECAUSE THEIR FAITH
MIGHT INTERFERE
WITH THE BUSINESS.
Shannon: ELYSE.
I THINK THIS TIME
SHE IS STRUGGLING THROUGH
UNHEALTHY EATING HABITS,
AND THAT COULD HARM HER
IN THE FUTURE.
I DON'T WANNA BE THE ONE
TO JUDGE.
Kesse: ELYSE,
BECAUSE I'M VERY WORRIED
ABOUT HER HEALTH.
Giselle: I DON'T THINK
I CAN GIVE YOU AN ANSWER.
I REALLY DON'T WANNA GIVE
AN ANSWER.
I HONESTLY DON'T.
Robin: I JUST PRAY
THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
I'M STILL HERE.
Tyra: YOU HAD
A MOVEMENT SHOOT,
AND WE PICKED YOUR BEST PHOTO,
AND HERE IT IS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT IT?
Robin: HONESTLY,
I'M LOOKIN' AT HIM.
AND I WAS THINKING, YOU KNOW,
DO PEOPLE REALLY, LIKE,
GO THROUGH THIS, YOU KNOW,
LIKE WORKING WITH OTHER PEOPLE?
Tyra: WAS HE TALKING ABOUT
YOUR BOOTY OR SOMETHING?
Robin: HE WAS LUSTIN'.
Tyra: DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOU HAVE TO GO TO BED
WITH HIM LATER, DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOU HAVE TO GIVE HIM
YOUR NUMBER.
IF SOMEBODY'S SAYIN', "DAMN,"
IT JUST MEANS
YOU'RE DOING GREAT.
Elyse: I LIKE IT A LOT.
Janice: YOU LOOK LIKE
A GAZELLE FROM
THE AMERICAN BALLET THEATRE.
I LOVE THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
Steve: SHE LOOKS LIKE A PRO.
Janice: SHE IS A PRO.
Elyse: I TALKED TO HIM
A LITTLE BIT BEFORE WE STARTED
AND I ASKED HIM, "I REALLY WANNA
TRY TO USE YOU."
I THINK MAYBE HE RESPONDED
TO THAT A LITTLE BIT.
Tyra: I LOVE THE FACT
THAT HE'S ENGAGED.
HE'S ALL INTO YOU.
Beau: IT'S FANTASTIC,
BUT I DO THINK
YOU LOOK A LITTLE BIT THIN.
I JUST WOULD HAVE
COVERED YOUR ARMS.
Janice: OH, PLEASE.
Adrianne: WOW,
LOOK AT MY MUSCLE.
Kimora: I THINK
IT'S A WONDERFUL PHOTO,
A WONDERFUL EXAMPLE OF
ARTISTIC EXPRESSION.
Tyra: I THOUGHT IT WAS
REALLY COOL THAT YOU WERE ABLE
TO MODEL WITH YOUR MOM THERE.
I CAN DO IT NOW,
BUT IN THE BEGINNING,
I COULD NOT HAVE MY MOM
LOOK AT ME OR ANYTHING.
I WAS LIKE,
"MAMA, GET OUT THE ROOM."
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Shannon: I LIKE IT.
Janice: THERE IS
NOTHING WRONG WITH THIS PICTURE.
IT'S EVERYTHING RIGHT.
Beau: I LOVE THAT PHOTOGRAPH.
Janice: YEAH, IT'S GREAT.
Tyra: THIS PICTURE IS HOT,
WHICH MEANS THAT THERE'S
A LOT MORE HOTNESS IN YOU,
BUT IT WAS DIFFICULT
GETTING IT OUT OF YOU.
Shannon: I'LL WORK ON THAT.
Giselle: WELL, IT DEFINITELY
SHOWS THAT I HAVE HAD
SOME TRAINING.
Janice: THIS PHOTOGRAPH
IS SURREAL, IT'S THAT GOOD.
Kimora: HOW HIGH
CAN YOU GET OFF THE FLOOR?
IT IS AMAZING.
Tyra: ONE THING
ABOUT THE CONFIDENCE THING--
I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
I HEARD YOU WALK OFF THE SET.
AND WHAT YOU WERE DOING--
YOU WERE FISHING--
Giselle: NO, NO, NO--
Tyra: AH-AH-AH-AH!
YOU WERE FISHING
FOR A COMPLIMENT.
SHE'S DOING THIS...
MM-MM-MM.
GIVE ME THE COMPLIMENT BACK.
(laughter)
Janice: ALL WOMEN
FISH FOR COMPLIMENTS.
Tyra: I LIKE IT.
I LIKE HOW YOU LOOK
YOUNG BUT SEXY.
Janice: THIS LOOKS LIKE
SHE ESCAPED
FROM A MENTAL INSTITUTION.
THIS IS THE WORST PHOTOGRAPH
I'VE EVER SEEN.
YOU LOOK DERANGED.
YOUR ARMS LOOK AMPUTEED.
YOUR LEGS LOOK AMPUTEED,
AND IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE
A PENIS, I'M SORRY.
Beau: I THINK IT'S ADORABLE.
Kimora: I THINK IT'S CRAZY,
LIKE, WHAT A LIKENESS
YOU ARE TO TYRA.
THAT FACE LOOKS LIKE TYRA TO ME.
Janice: THERE IT IS.
Kesse: THANK YOU.
Tyra: THANKS.
WHO ARE WE GONNA CUT THIS WEEK?
Steve: LET'S JUST CALL IT
AS IT IS.
ROBIN, FIRST OF ALL,
IS TOO OLD TO BE STARTING.
Janice: AND FAT. SHE'S HUGE.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO BE
A TOP MODEL.
Steve: SHE WON'T--
THAT'S THE REALITY.
Janice: SHE WOULD WORK
FOR A CAR TARPAULIN COMPANY.
Tyra: I THINK THAT YOU GUYS
ARE THE PROBLEM WITH AMERICA.
I THINK YOU ARE THE PROBLEM
OF WHY WOMEN ARE LEANING
OVER THEIR TOILETS AT
THIS VERY MOMENT AND VOMITING
AFTER THEY'VE EATEN
OR TAKEN LAXATIVES
AFTER THEY'VE EATEN.
THE FULL FIGURED MARKET'S
CHANGING.
OKAY. SHANNON.
Beau: SHANNON DOESN'T
IMPRESS ME SOMETIMES
SO MUCH IN PERSON,
BUT SHE COMES UP WELL ON FILM.
Steve: I THINK SHE CAN BE
A TOP MODEL WITHOUT A DOUBT.
Beau: I LOVE
ADRIANNE'S PHOTOGRAPHS,
AND I THINK THAT SHE KEEPS
GETTING BETTER AND BETTER
EACH WEEK, I THINK.
Janice: BUT THE TONE
OF HER SPEECH
ANSWERING STEVE'S QUESTIONS
REALLY MADE ME WANNA CRINGE.
Beau: IN.
Tyra: IN.
Steve: KESSE, I WOULD SAY,
ON THE INTERVIEW LEVEL--
SHE TALKS--SHE SPEAKS WELL.
Beau: YOU SHOULD HAVE
SEEN HER WHEN SHE FIRST CAME IN.
SHE'S ACTUALLY GROWN.
Janice: GISELLE, FOR ME,
IS THE BEST MOVER.
Tyra: WHEN I LOOK
AT GISELLE'S PICTURES,
I SEE A DANCER.
Steve: I THINK THAT
HER LACK OF CONFIDENCE
IS JUST SOMETHING SHE'S
PUTTING OUT THERE,
BUT I THINK THE WAY
SHE MOVES HERE IS BY FAR
THE MOVES OF A CONFIDENT WOMAN.
Kimora: OUT.
Steve: IN.
Kimora: ELYSE IS NOT
PERSONALLY MY TYPE OF GIRL.
THE EATING DISORDER THING
IS JUST A STRONG, STRONG ISSUE
FOR ME.
Janice: DROP
THE EATING DISORDER.
THAT'S HEARSAY.
SHE'S EXTREMELY THIN,
WHICH IS WHAT
A HAUTE COUTURE MODEL NEEDS.
Kimora: BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE, YOU KNOW, AMERICA'S QUEST
FOR THE PRETTIEST ANOREXIC
EITHER.
Steve: THERE'S GIRLS
THAT LOOK LIKE THIS
THAT ARE SUPERSTARS.
Janice: I AGREE.
Steve: LINDA EVANGELISTA
WAS A RAIL.
COME ON.
Beau: LINDA EVANGELISTA
WAS NEVER A RAIL.
I'VE WORKED WITH HER
SEVERAL TIMES.
Steve: KATE MOSS, TWIGGY.
Janice: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
I'M SEEING IT.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: THERE ARE SIX OF YOU
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FIVE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE FIVE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE FIVE OF YOU
THAT ARE STILL RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ADRIANNE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
KESSE. CONGRATULATIONS.
SHANNON.
BEAUTY DOES NOT MAKE
A TOP MODEL--NOT JUST BEAUTY.
YOU HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO MOVE.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Robin: ROBIN.
WE DON'T WANNA SEE YOU
ON YOUR HIGH HORSE
AND SHOWING THE WORLD
HOW GREAT YOU ARE.
SHOW THE WORLD
HOW HUMAN YOU ARE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL GISELLE AND ELYSE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Elyse: MY ENTIRE ATTITUDE
TOWARDS THIS COMPETITION
HAS BEEN PRETTY FATALISTIC,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I THINK IT IS EMBARRASSING
TO BE ELIMINATED,
AND I DON'T WANT IT
TO HAPPEN TO ME.
Tyra: ELYSE,
YOU ARE AN INTELLIGENT WOMAN,
WHICH IS AN AMAZING TRAIT,
ESPECIALLY BEING
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
WHERE THE STEREOTYPE
IS THAT MODELS ARE STUPID.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOT
BE ON THIS "I'M SO BETTER
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE"
KIND OF ATTITUDE.
IT ONLY MAKES PEOPLE
NOT LIKE YOU.
NOT APPRECIATE
YOUR INTELLIGENCE.
Giselle: I'M NERVOUS
ONCE AGAIN.
I REALLY--I JUST--I REALLY
DON'T WANNA GET ELIMINATED.
I'M ENJOYING MYSELF SO MUCH.
Tyra: GISELLE,
AGAIN, WE TALKED ABOUT
YOUR CONFIDENCE.
DURING THE PHOTO SHOOT,
I THOUGHT YOU WERE
ACTUALLY THE BEST
IN TERMS OF MOVEMENT,
BUT YOU WALKED OFF THE STAGE,
AND YOU SAID,
"I THINK I MESSED UP
BECAUSE I THINK I LOOK MORE
LIKE A DANCER THAN A MODEL,"
AND YOU MADE MY MIND CHANGE.
CONGRATULATIONS, ELYSE.
Giselle: I JUST KNEW
THAT IT WAS MY TIME TO GO.
Giselle: BRITNEY SPEARS
DID "STAR SEARCH," AND SHE LOST,
AND LOOK AT WHERE SHE'S AT NOW,
SO I MAY--I MEAN, I DON'T
CONSIDER MYSELF A LOSER.
IT SUCKS THAT I'M GONNA GO
FROM ALL THIS TO BACK HOME
WHERE IT'S NORMAL.
MY MOM--I KNOW SHE'S GONNA
RUB IT IN MY FACE,
SO THAT'LL PROBABLY
BE THE ONLY THING.
I'M GONNA FEEL CRAPPY.
BECAUSE IF I'M COMING
HOME, IT'S BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
I DIDN'T DO SO WELL HERE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Robin: OH MY WORD!
Tyra: THE GIRLS TAKE ON
THE FASHION CAPITOL
OF THE WORLD
AND CRAMPED
QUARTERS CREATE CONTEMPT.
Robin: I AIN'T GOT NO
CLOTHES ON.
Adrianne: HOW DO YOU SAY
ADRIANNE HAS ENORMOUS CHA-CHAS?
Robin: I DON'T SPEAK LIKE THAT
AND I DON'T ACT LIKE THAT.
Tyra: AND AT A SEXY PHOTO SHOOT
SHANNON GETS THE SURPRISE
OF HER LIFE
Shannon: OH MY WORD!